Books are incredible...
...in the sense that they are usually thousands...
...or many thousands of hours of work, and energy, and knowledge,...
...condensed into a few hundred pages.
The author is imparting in you a piece of their lives,...
...of what they know, or their imagination.
A part of them, basically.
It's actually a beautiful concept if you think about it.
I have a few book recommendations,...
...but I'm gonna save that for the second half of this video.
And, like I said before, reading transports you to another place.
And I used to think that was exclusive to fiction,...
...but that's not true at all.
Like I said, it was only recently, last summer actually,...
...that I rediscovered books through my smartphone, actually.
Believe it or not.
Things always go full circle.
It's amazing.
I mainly listen to them in the morning when I go running, when I'm cooking,...
...or before I go to bed.
But they're also wonderful to listen to when you're exploring the city,...
...or you know, when I'm coloring footage.
I think I was really hungry for new perspectives and insights on life.
And now I'm just trying to make up for lost time...
...because there's just something amazing about books,..
...and how they're able to expand your mind and perspective.
I think it's fair to say there isn't another medium that can go deeper on a topic.